this is a crazy story this is from our
good friends over at Jezebel you know
Jezebel you know
twitch twitch's AI porn controversy is a
creepy sign of things to come you know I
completely agree with Jezebel for once
popular streamer attracts sobbed through
his apology after viewers spotted that
he was looking at AI generated porn of
other streamers this is the weirdest
thing ever so the dude I guess like
what's the story he was what he had porn
pulled up on his no he like so pop
culture crisis shout out to them talked
about this the other day he like was
doing a stream and he was clicking
through like the tabs and I guess I
don't know if he opened accidentally or
just skipped over it but like they could
see he was on PornHub and I don't know
all the details of like how they
identified that it was what it is it
wasn't PornHub for my image it was a
site that does this you can like upload
someone's face in his apology he said I
was on PornHub and I got directed to an
app right exactly and then it sent me to
whoever something that's what I figured
out but like they noticed a tab in his
browser that was like it was crying
about it yeah
his wife is crying too he was on point
he was like I was on porn of a totally
normal site and then I an ad popped up
famously an ad popped up for this AI
deep fake porn so he clicked on it and
then he went the extra step to pay money
to get an account for the connecting to
watch can I just give some advice to any
uh you know young streamers out there
you have a work computer and your
personal computer it's not hard to
understand but this guy apparently was
like I run my business off this machine
let's pull up adult content on the
browser I use yeah for children come on
bro like a streamer for like a year a
long time right like I think he was I
don't know anything about him but
obviously he was live what am I saying
think yeah but I just mean like you you
think he'd know to close his tabs yeah
seriously bro come on just don't do that
on your work computer just don't do it
at all in my opinion true true as the
story was breaking what's this girl's
name out of a morbid curiosity he paid
for a subscription
so curious please have my money and show
me more yeah I think he's in damage
control at this point remember hold on
like
how I mean it is it is kind of CR it is
creepy right do we have super creepy
it's creepy so then what what do you do
right if there's like some sort of
initiative to censor this sort of
content that's worse I mean I don't know
yeah someone someone tweeted this and I
saw it's got to 11 600 quote tweets this
tweet has 36 million views this guy I uh
ion romaro says millionaire internet
streamers reaction to AI porn of herself
you won't find more fragile people than
popular internet personalities
especially women I don't know if I agree
um I think you're allowed to be freaked
out that someone took a picture of your
face and put it on porn and is like
watching it she says people keep sending
screenshots of it to her like all these
people have seen it and it's got her
face on it and then like I mean it
happens to celebrities all the time
doesn't it you know their faces are
drama did this yeah remember when when
fry was dating Lucy lubot oh yeah yeah
he had Lucy Liu downloaded into a robot
yeah well that's true I already used
example pop culture but uh Japan has
this big issue with importing sex dolls
and they've agreed to release some but
they won't release any that look like a
public figure or like a child
yeah because they're like that's
disgusting so what's a public figure at
the end of days well I know like how do
you define what a public figure exactly
do you have to be in a magazine to be in
a movie also how are like all of the
people so you can do it to regular
people or like 2 000 followers on it's
like what point yeah exactly it's
terrifying and like there have been a
lot of people saying they shouldn't be
upset about this but like I think people
will compare it to like oh it's like a
sex tape getting weak but like this girl
who's crying about it like didn't didn't
do that like I mean I understand
about it she's also not making money off
of it and I'm sure that's not her point
but yeah that's part of her Point yeah
yeah but she should get all the money
from it she should it's her lightness
like you can't take a picture of Ian and
put it on like a commercial for your
soda pop you got to pay in for that well
you can do it but you will pay me for it
if you do no no look at this look at
this this tweet from sweet Anita said
the story was how I found out that I'm
on this website I literally choose to
pass up Millions by not going into sex
work and some random Cheeto encrusted
porn addicts unless it's my body without
my consent instead don't know whether
whether the cry breaks up or laugh at
this point I just don't think this
should be the price for wanting to
entertain people this made me realize
something
there's a lot of women who try to do
only fans they could effectively have
like like porn star surrogates you know
yeah like you don't have to extrude
themselves but here's here's but here's
the problem that's that's the thing I'm
saying like there could be women who are
like get a different woman to do the
work for you just put your face on it
but here's the crazy thing
you can't do anything about it so we're
we're talking about we're working on
music and we were talking with some some
you know industry guys and they were
like you actually do a cover of a song
you know people like covers and then you
do like maybe just like one cover of
something as like a song you really like
you want to do and I'm like well how do
you do that I mean we got to buy the
right snark no you just do it no because
I'm like fine you don't need to buy the
rights to cover a song like no the money
just goes to the person who wrote the
song right I was like oh wow now think
about what that means for AI deep porn
that means any woman anywhere can't stop
someone from making it the only thing
they can do is accept the money this
basically means like you cannot stop
someone from forcing a woman to be in in
in AI porn yeah the only thing that
happens is like well they used your face
so here's money so how do you deal with
this that's the question I don't know
the girl in the video and I I apologize
I don't know her name GT Cinderella I
mean like I feel bad for her she's not
happening today how do you how do you
deal she says one of her frustrations
now she's taking she's spending her own
money to fight it like in court and
stuff and I guess like you issue a cease
and desist like but the other part is
good luck also it's already out there
like even if you get this one video of
her taken down it doesn't end the
surface and also like
is going to be able to write it on the
spot you'll go I want to watch Person a
have sex with animal L and then they
watch a donkey and uh the woman you love
getting it on and then you like okay
stop I want to watch myself having sex
with fill in the blank and it's that's
it and everyone in the world is fair
game you could even be I want to look at
a blend of person A and B having sex
with person Y and you'll see like these
weird dude people are gonna like put the
Hulk's face on a woman I remember
talking about that weird YouTube thing
where they put Hitler's head on a
woman's body to do tai chi and sing
nursery rhymes to kids
man the world is is getting technology
it feels like thank you it feels like
chaos is taking over it's just
everything's becoming random nonsense
and chaotic but then eventually it'll
become normalized and then people you
know that's why I asked if we'll be
around in 14 years that this country's
can still it's like we used to be able
to defend Earth because of land borders
they had artillery they rolled up to the
Border we could protect it with troops
they couldn't get any closer in so they
couldn't hit the target now we have air
power you can't protect the earth when
everyone has air power there's no way to
defend the American process of Defending
Earth is not functional now because you
have orbital strikes and stuff climate
change is supposed to kill us by 2025 so
so wait these websites allow you to like
you upload someone else's picture and
then it'll generate it for you yeah I
know they do those we did the thing with
the music video genocide if you haven't
seen heard the song genocide check it
out because Ian's in it and we we
animated news personality faces to sing
the song about it's basically
criticizing the media for being Liars
yeah so I know that that sounds like you
know kind of wholesome it's silly to
like make Don Lemon sing or whatever but
people are actually going totally dark
with it it's crazy I I wanted to get an
account and check it out earlier today
but I stopped myself
not enough morbid curiosity you know
what I would actually rather do I would
rather just use it use like the AI
technology to put Tom Cruise in just
whatever movie so like I want to see Tom
Cruise as Frodo Baggins and then do a
voice Ai and a face Ai and then it's
literally just Tom Cruise as Frodo bangs
the whole time tell me that would not be
like the funnest thing ever it would be
fun to have technology if everyone had
good intentions right but like you can't
introduce that you have to assume
everyone's gonna do the worst thing
which is like you know AI generated porn
like I'm sorry but that's the reality I
mean people can already do that with
like Adobe programs and everything put
you know your face on video and Etc so
it's true I don't like anything to AI
they're just making it easier with AI to
do that yeah of course but I think
that's like that's why you so many
parents are deciding not to put their
kids faces on the internet right that's
why you saw this pushback against like
family family Vlog channels I think that
like
we had a nice honeymoon here here with
technology and the internet we thought
it was cool we thought it was a fun time
but actually it's extremely dangerous it
is and there's no putting it back in the
box so should you just I'm just I'm just
worried about what politicians are gonna
propose to stop this from happening oh I
got an idea we should uh AI Biden's face
on Trump's body and then start showing
it to people and be like do you agree
with what Joe Biden says here yep
totally and it'll be Joe bidenberg come
on man you know I'm the greatest
president everybody agrees yeah that's a
good idea we could honestly do like a
Nancy Pelosi or a foucho and you haven't
did voices down you know I feel like uh
it's it's inevitable that everyone's
going to be defect onto porn of all
styles yeah so I've just kind of already
accepted it like get ready for the
Whirlwind but the problem is when people
don't know it's a deep fake when they
see it yeah and then they post that's
the problem and even law enforcement
when it happens so often and people are
gonna just be like oh it's probably fake
and the noise
and you go to the cops and they're like
nah everything's fake it's the matter
but it's a real case like what do we do
they would have the means to you know
sort of investigate it but you just said
to it that everyone's gonna assume it's
all fake everyone is in general public
but I think forensics will dig through
it yeah if they are motivated enough to
right if we assume enough of it is fake
I'm just saying like it opens this
terrible door where people are going to
be like the reality is most this stuff
is not real but like what's real that's
the question is is it the perception of
the act or is it the act itself because
when you watch porn a video you're not
actually watching the porn you're
watching a digital representation of us
you're not watching porn for real you're
watching a a fantasy um
that's a semantic argument but we think
it's real because we feel it because it
happened because people filmed it we're
asking the question of whether or not it
was filmed with real humans or was made
by a computer and it never happened if
it looks identical like what's if
there's no difference there is was a
person in this act or not and if we're
talking about children would say
children harmed and raped or as an adult
who consented and got paid I mean those
are questions is it a video evidence of
a crime or not that's you know very
simple but until those if I don't think
those questions can be answered if it
looks realistic and if there's no way to
know well you should be able to answer
it like you said
I'm not saying hey Authority is going to
fix it I don't know I'm not entirely
convinced because this is something
we've been talking about for several
years okay and it's going to come to a
point where what you do is you create
and you you generate a fake video then
you come you run it through a compressor
or or uh you convert it and now it it
wipes out the artifacts yeah it's gonna
be it's going to be hard to tell at a
certain really good job interesting yeah
yep it's creepy I was watching um
I was watching some YouTube videos like
some blizzard thing or something I
remember what it was no no no no uh yeah
yeah I can't remember what it was and it
was like
it was kind of really obvious it was CGI
but just the lighting was so good I was
like weird it was like they got past The
Uncanny Valley that's what it felt like
it felt like you knew it was CGI but it
looked so good and real and it was like
a person walking like across a bridge or
something and I was like damn this is
creepy that's crazy stuff man yeah I to
go back to the crying girl for just a
second because on my mind
um the other thing I think she could do
legally is go after PornHub because if
they're accepting advertising money from
this site I don't really I'm not a
lawyer I don't know she could no okay
but like you gotta go to the company
that did it not the advertising like
they can't she can maybe do a cease and
desist if they're showing her major on
the side or something I feel like there
is like that's what's weirding me out
like I'm not gonna start a new wave of
lawsuits I know but like that's the
thing about legal fights like everyone
involved has to have the money to go
through it and even then they're not
always effective like there's really no
justice for this and they're also buying
his story about that's what happened oh
yeah for sure sure I feel like and I
don't know I'm not gonna investigate it
but like him being like these are
advertising they see there are enough
people who check out PornHub who could
verify oh yeah they run those
advertisements which is like to me
creepy I'm like I got a weird gross man
yeah it's terrible I met like a
Crossroads in my mind because I'm like a
pretty extreme techno libertarian like I
think if the technology can exist it's
gonna exist and it will get used no
amount of legalities are gonna stop that
technology from being real
uh but then I'm like well wait a minute
I'm thinking about protecting children
and like how do you
how to you know you can't just let
everyone see everything all the time
where where we're going like remember
lenza that it was a big thing it's I
guess people are still doing it the AI
pictures like the cartoon pictures and
everything you take a bunch of pictures
of yourself and it generates like a
perfect AI version of you or whatever
that's the future we're gonna live in
the pods and you're gonna be in a
digital world and you know the funny
thing is like for all we know we're
already in it and we are the beautiful
versions of ourselves dude I just pulled
up this story from last year on Yahoo
would you eat lab-grown human salami
cultured from celebrity cells oh they're
making meat from celebrities oh they're
about to and then you can eat your
favorite celebrity thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time